[Music]
who smells bacon
before we smell big do you guys got any
news or are we just in like the deepest
doldrums of the end of History let's go
to the let's go to the front page of CNN
and see what's going on
Disney scraps plans foreign
go woke go broke yeah exactly yeah I
wasn't Disney in the the uh Florida
government were kind of antagonizing one
another uh I think the government was
threatening to build something on or
near a space that Disney uses yes
beside like Disney World and just ahead
of his announcement His official
announcement for like the presidential
campaign next week Disney decides to
tell him we're actually not going to
build our campus on in Florida we're not
going to bring thousands of jobs to your
state so
why is it because they're they're awoken
he's anti-woo yeah he's a very
distasteful human yeah he's like the
most lizard lizard type person I've seen
you're not going to have any of the
Disney characters Goofy's not going to
be in his uh on his chain gang in his
black and white striped pajamas have you
seen those weird videos of him trying to
act like Trump like he's like he's like
trying to adopt like Trump's mannerisms
and like or even trying to act like a
normal human like just him laughing it's
really unnatural
uh apparently the the Disney is engaging
in lgbtq plus advocacy which violates
the don't say gay laws uh so DeSantis
was using some leverage to I don't I
don't know what he thought Disney was
gonna do be like all right
it's like I mean there's this recent
story a couple days ago about uh I think
it was yesterday actually a Florida
teacher is being investigated for
showing a Disney film in class that had
a gay character in it and they're
investigating whether this violates the
uh don't say gay laws wait Disney has
openly gay characters now I thought it
was usually
it's a film called Strange World and
apparently it features a gay character
they were mermaids and the the I guess
the implication was that they were like
living amongst the the regular folk but
hiding their mermaideness but they were
allowed to come out of the mermaid
closet right well wasn't that original
Like Fable by whoever Hans Christian
Anderson like was supposed to be like a
metaphor for his own struggle of like a
little mermaid yeah yeah it's been read
as like a queer sort of fairy tale
there's but that that was sort of played
down in the Disney version like of
course obviously obviously
in the new one with Javier Bardem as her
father oh here's another thing so an
interesting yeah
ambiguous uh yeah here's another here's
other here's other like random news that
isn't from this week that like we could
talk about is this Cleopatra documentary
on Netflix that people are up in arms
about what what people rich people
people online Egyptians are actually up
in arms this one's really funny yeah
because it's not your the usual crowd
complaining about it so yeah Netflix has
this documentary on Cleopatra and she's
portrayed by a black actress or this
British mixed race actress and it was
actually people in Egypt who were like
you're appropriating our culture for
like some sort of woke Hollywood thing
yeah Cleopatra was not black she was
messed
wasn't she Greek or something like
Macedonian yeah she was descended from
like this you know she was like the last
Pharaoh and her lineage was was
originally from Greece but it's there's
some slight question mark about you know
whether she had some mixed Egyptian
background too but Netflix went like
full sort of like you know black panther
with it apparently and Egypt was not
having it and well apparently there's a
part there's a part in it where like
some woman is just like who's like a
historian and or something I can't
remember I don't know because I haven't
watched it but like there's apparently
some scene that people are up in arms
about or like some black woman is just
like my mom told me like don't let them
lie to you like Cleopatra was black and
it's just like apparently like not based
on anything it's just like some woman
talking about her like Mom said like you
shouldn't believe what they say and it's
like and a lot of I mean I think that
angered Egyptians and then like
historians were just like well this
isn't based on anything this is just but
that's the thing though like yeah that's
what's really cool Egypt and Cleopatra
are like bigger than actual Egypt it's
like a whole concept right it's like
this whole idea of like the original
sort of African civilization so yeah in
some ways yeah like there there is this
sort of version of Cleopatra which is
sort of you know part of the Black
Culture but then you get to the real
Egyptians it's it's a it's a bit messy
yeah yeah and Egypt too at that time
wasn't it what wasn't it like I don't
know what the I mean it's hard to know
like what complexion they would have
been back then right like because a lot
of Egypt now isn't it like hasn't it
changed because like at the time of
ancient Egypt like ethnically it would
have been different because it's changed
a lot as a result of like the like yeah
yeah it's right it's a bit tricky
because not not to get too sidetracked
with this but like yeah they were always
like Mediterranean obviously but they
were also like you know then you also
had like a sort of Arab Invasion and
stuff so I think the populations have
stayed pretty consistent but yeah
they're they're not like you know
they're not sub-Saharan African that's
that's for sure yeah but yeah
Netflix is waded into this without
consulting us so that's that's the
problem yeah a rerun of the uh old black
Athena
yeah it's a big woke off competition
cultural appropriation versus
representation and look I asked for news
and all the news we have is who's mad
about which people being represented in
which IP this is this is the 2023
political project it's kind of a sequel
to the black Athena controversy back in
the late 80s when that book came out and
uh they were trying to highlight the uh
the afro-asiatic roots of of ancient of
classical culture and I do made a big
stink over that too yeah exactly I mean
it's it's you know it's like a stupid
thing I mean I will I have to say I do
give like Netflix some credit for like
remaining consistent on their message of
just like we will put up content from
like you know whatever we want right
like so they get criticized for putting
like anti-wo content up like putting
Chappelle's comedy but then they'll put
this up and they put up like so it's
just like they just put up whatever they
think is gonna make the money and it's
like you know he figured out the secret
yeah exactly you've heard him and we
should introduce him in case you for
tasty listeners don't know but uh lit
Vic is here
to rewind the clock a little bit we're
going before end of this uh woke stuff
came about we're reading a very
political well not very Politically
Incorrect slightly Politically Incorrect
story
the news in the headlines is uh the 30
Years War
it's been what 30 years since the
Spanish Armada Was Defeated and we're
good in back in good old England looking
now not at the Twilight but the sunrise
of capitalism
Victor heard us Victor hannahju lit Vic
heard us do an episode on Atlantis
and thought that it would be a good
follow-up to do Bacon's new Atlantis I
don't know why we haven't discussed why
but we all read it and we are yeah we're
gonna we're gonna get taught the
relevance important significance what to
get out of it how to read it in parallel
to our times today it's also worth it
that lip Vic here also for those who
don't know him is maybe close to I don't
know where you're at with your PhD but
is doing a PhD in in English literature
so you know that's his wheelhouse that's
his ABD yeah so uh it's true yeah so
bacon modern right Victor early
modernist as they say yeah so I'm not
looking directly at bacon I look more at
the Mediterranean region in this time
but yeah definitely kind of like
England's the the early days of
England's Empire like way before the
British Empire was actually powerful but
when it was kind of you know starting to
expand the focus that it kind of had you
know on its travel writing and stuff
like that so yeah I mean the real reason
why I think uh new Atlantis is
interesting first of all is maybe we can
get to the bottom of the Cleopatra
Netflix controversy because
everything does go back to Egypt
actually as we know even with the
original Atlantis from Plato but um
yeah this is just like a really
interesting text it's it's not very long
it was published uh actually after bacon
died so it was unfinished but it's sort
of it's it's this weird sort of uh
utopian take on the new world the
so-called new world of the Americas and
it kind of shows you just how much you
know bacon and other writers of that
time were sort of bringing a lot of
cultural baggage with them to the new
hemisphere and projecting a lot of old
ideas about Europe and Atlantis and sort
of these foundational cultural
narratives that they had onto these new
lands that they were starting to just
like map out for the first time so
I guess the the interesting context here
first of all is like before this time
when bacon was writing this sort of you
know like early utopian kind of text the
the world view that a lot of Europeans
had especially like the Middle Ages was
much more about like a sense of
spiritual geography right so you kind of
had these maps of the world which had
Jerusalem at the center they were the
three continents of like Europe Africa
and Asia the famous SEO Maps exactly
yeah yeah so that all kind of changes
with the sort of you know the age of
expansion the age of Discovery if you
will with Christopher Columbus and the
Renaissance when the Americas are kind
of put on the map for Europe and for the
first time there's this sense of like a
new world right this this broader sense
of expanded Frontiers but what you see
with writers like bacon and even to an
extent like Thomas More before him who
wrote like Utopia the original sort of
utopian text about a century earlier is
that they weren't they were first and
foremost interested in kind of like
using these New Frontiers to sort of
explore their own cultural history
further they weren't really just like
you know they weren't that interested in
encountering actual difference or actual
different cultures it was more a case of
like okay what does this new world sort
of tell us about our own right
so I I would actually kind of compare it
to um it's almost like a science fiction
Trope where in many cases you guys might
have noticed like the aliens in science
fiction films or something like that
like they're not really that different
ultimately from you know the cultures
that we're more familiar with like
whatever Avatar Star Wars they're all
kind of like thinly disguised histories
of our own sort of societies and in that
sense like we're not actually interested
in real difference right in like real
like really being sort of like
challenged from our World Views we'd
rather just have something that kind of
validates our own like cultures our own
history so I think that's also very
apparent in the way that early Europeans
at least were sort of like looking at
the Americas where like they weren't
really ready yet to kind of process this
whole new sort of you know like set of
civilizations or indigenous cultures
they'd rather just talk about Atlantis
again basically but in the context of
this new hemisphere so that's sort of
the starting point for thinking about
like what's bacon doing here why is he
kind of like interested in bringing up
these old myths in the context of this
really like the age of Discovery and
stuff like that yeah I was calling them
I was calling the new atlanteans Vulcans
you know they we they they the Europeans
get on to uh ship travel and then they
encounter the uh new atlanteans just as
light speed travels invented and
suddenly bump into the Vulcans in Star
Trek let's see but I wonder if people
read this like literally in the sense
that hey they're super Advanced
civilizations out there or if they're
just like you know
people don't really read it that way I
don't know how they read it but you know
it's projecting an idealized kind of
notion of their own Society onto
somewhere else more so than like
the mystery of discovering because it
Europe considered themselves to be the
most advanced I guess this is kind of
more projected yeah definitely it's
you're you're you're right that it's
almost more like speculative fiction
like no no one's sort of reading this
like and literally believing that you
know the sort of the science fiction
society that that bacon sort of talks
about is actually out there but it's
more like what is this sort of saying
about you know their own countries
England at the time and stuff like that
so
Netflix continually recommends to me is
called uh ancient apocalypse or some or
some hair brain like
pseudoscientist believes that there was
a super Advanced civilization that
existed before yeah Ice Age but this is
also like Mormonism right because they
show up in where is it Peru and
everyone's already Christians and
they're already better they're better
Christians than the Europeans are gotta
say I got really stoned and watched
ancient apocalypse and I gotta say it
was pretty fun
also bacon was like a he I don't know
what you call him full-blown science
[__] he was a Statesman but he's a
renaissance man is what you call him
yeah he did he's very he's very into uh
colonization they they got a stamp in
Newfoundland for him he had like uh like
again I don't know if he owned them but
he
he proffered the the Virginia
territories and the Virginia settlements
and wanted and saw that this was a
frontier worth pursuing
yeah it's it's just worth quickly
pointing out yeah so he was actually
quite heavily involved in promoting at
Britain's early colonies in Virginia and
especially Newfoundland as well yeah I
think he set up the Newfoundland company
and stuff like that so he was mostly
like he's mostly known now as this sort
of you know philosopher the father of
empiricism basically he was very
influential in developing the scientific
method but he was also during his time
like this you know parliamentarian this
politician and this promoter of early
modern colonialism and that intersects
in interesting ways as we'll see in this
text because it is ostensibly about you
know the new world and colonization but
it's also very much like it shows
Bacon's deep interest in the advancement
of Science and knowledge and those kinds
of things so yeah what's interesting
what you said about like how some of
these stories like tell us more about
ourselves
um rather than like actually being
interested in difference I mean
immediately you you mentioned like Star
Wars and some other stuff like Star Trek
which Eric mentioned like if you think
about what Star Trek was doing right it
was really like a reflection of
conflicts that were happening in in the
real world at the time like the original
Star Trek there's a reason that there
was you know a Soviet like Russian
person on the bridge of the Enterprise
because it was during the Cold War and
then like all the aliens they meet is
like kind of a metaphor for conflicts
that are happening
um in real life and and to some extent I
can see how this maps I mean one of the
ways that like it's funny how in this
story like they're they s their
representation of the new Atlantis is
almost like
like the ultimate version of like virtue
at the top of like accounting account of
virtue at the time because like it seems
like he describes the society as like
well they're Christian first of all
which is kind of funny right they're
like how did you look you've been inside
yeah so how did they get to be
Christians one of Jesus disciples got on
a boat and like in in in the first
century and got over the water somehow
and it's supposed to be near Peru right
yeah yeah it's so wild there's there's
so many things to unpack there in terms
of like how how it's just a it's such a
mishmash of like you know the ideal
European Christian scientific Society
yeah do we want to actually just sort of
like back up a little bit and maybe just
give an overview like what did we
actually encounter there what is the
story about yeah could you could you
give that account since you're the
you're the sure yeah it's it's very
quick again it's a very quick read 30 40
pages
um it's it's essentially just like this
sort of um ostensibly a travel account
of this group of sailors who end up sort
of stranded off the coast of Peru this
is the early 17th century and they find
this island called Ben solemn and it's
sort of it's filled with these really
Advanced kind of like almost Society of
religious scientists they have all this
incredible technology very science
fiction again and they are Christian
notably as well as you guys know saw and
then the whole language yeah they speak
their language but he points out he's
like Latin in Hebrew by the way these
people aren't like everyone else in the
in the new world they're not running
around naked they're not running around
naked these are Advanced people they're
not Native Americans that's the first
thing yeah so that's yeah that's sort of
the context for like him then going on
and sort of explaining well this is
what's so great about their society this
is all the Marvels they have and then he
kind of learns about how they became
Christian all that other stuff but yeah
it's it's very wild how they they really
are almost like idealized Europeans that
this you know in this fantasy world
rather than indigenous Americans or
anything like that so there's even Jews
living there uh peacefully yeah oh he
goes off he has to point this out too
these aren't like the Jews we have back
home these ones are actually good and
they're integrated into society yeah
there's lots of things that are like
strange but not too strange and
unexpected like they'll say he came out
with a big turbanon but it wasn't quite
as big as the ones the Turks wear and it
had a cross at the top of it it so it's
like just different enough but kind of
you know you know they they do things
just like us but better right they they
avoid the pitfalls of the way Europeans
do things like it's always presented as
like here it's strange but then he like
kind of pulls it back a bit and that's
that's one of the conceits to like the
whole travel writing genre at the time
so there was this great interest of
course in like all these like new look
new worlds and far-off places and stuff
and people would learn about them by
reading accounts from Travelers who had
been there so the idea was at least okay
this is like you know a reputable
account from somebody who's actually
been there no matter how crazy it is you
have to believe it because they they saw
it but this is also where you kind of
get to like more utopian speculative
fiction where of course this is a
fantasy this is not real and the readers
would not have believed that this
actually happened but it kind of plays
off of the more realistic travel writing
genre that's where if bacon kind of like
starts with this stuff where like okay
aruza real place this is all kind of
like like you've read something like
this before which is real but I'm gonna
go in a totally different direction and
basically do more like you know a sort
of Plato's Republic spin on this where
it's like what if you know at the edge
of the world we find like the perfect
Society what would that look like so
right right and it's kind of like he
includes these things like oh they
buried their pots like the Chinese do
like Eric said they wear their turbans
like the Turks do it's like this
Pinnacle of society that takes the
little good pieces of both and of course
Christianity and and they're better
Christians than Europeans are they yeah
they live their faith
Yeah so basically yeah he has like a
conversation with like a few different
people I think like three or four
different people and and then we just
sort of learn about the society in
different phases
so like we kind of get this whole ritual
first where they are stopped before they
can approach and they actually asked the
people on the ship the the uh the
atlanteans ask them if they are
Christians and force them to swear it
and then they go on to be quarantined
for a while and then he has a few
conversations which bring out like
different aspects of the society so they
talk about like kind of the
the guests laws and the law Giver of the
society and the science and this like
weird father ritual where like if you've
had if you're if you're a man and you're
alive and you have 30 children that are
at least three years of age then you get
to do this wonderful ceremony and then
you're brought into this like almost
upper echelon of society that we don't
actually get any insight into but
they're just the fathers of the house
and then they and then one of them
actually comes down and speaks to the
narrator sort of right at the end and
tells them all about their science and
then it just kind of breaks off there
permits them to publish this work
because they're very secretive right
there they're observers but they're not
observed right they are these secret
people who learn from the rest of the
world but they they keep bragging about
like how they've got eyes in Europe
they're like we've seen everything we
know about you guys but like yeah they
like they actively collect knowledge
while keeping themselves solves like
kind of mysterious and unknown they know
without being known they see without
being seen kind of stuff
they're very chaste they don't allow
they don't allow homosexuals or
courtesans and I was wondering with this
whole like emphasis on on their their
Christian meet
because what's going on in a like
Germany's engulfed in war at this time
and
the uh
I guess the English are mostly taking a
financial position like supporting the
Dutch and like fighting against the the
habsburgs but is there this thought that
this is the redeemed Christianity where
everyone lives at peace because they
obviously don't have denominations
there's no Anglican Catholic Protestant
but in in what way is this a reflection
on the situation in Europe while this is
being written
yeah yeah so bacon himself he was deeply
religious as you can tell in this work
and he was Anglican which was sort of
the English denomination but this is
before England had its own religious
civil wars in the mid-1600s so this is
sort of like the Calm before the storm
there yeah and you can tell bacon is
really kind of sort of showing this
idealized view like as you said of of
Christianity free from denominations
it's very idealized and it also kind of
plays on um this is something that
Thomas Moore did again a century earlier
in his novel Utopia where you have this
Society living off in the in the
Americas of idealized kind of like
Kingdom where they weren't technically
Christians in Utopia but the way that
they act is actually better than the
Christians in Europe in terms of how
virtuous they are and everything so in
this case again like bacon is kind of
using this you know science fiction
Fantasy Island to almost like comment on
you know how badly Europeans are sort of
you know doing in their own religious
practices at the time that kind of show
like this is the gold standard and this
is how much you know we are like failing
to live up to that sort of you know so
in that way yeah the this question of
kind of you know the the Christianity in
the society is is much more of a
commentary on the the tumult the
religious kind of turmoil in Europe at
the time and you know how much there was
going on there
is the most interesting part is about
the science bit right but if you
actually add up the words the science
bit is very small whereas like yeah how
much he talks about marriage and ritual
and like you're allowed to see your wife
naked once before you get married just
to make sure she has no like hidden not
even direct properties yeah a friend of
yours is allowed to see the wife through
like a reflection or something yeah he
can look into the pool and you're
allowed to see her reflection in the
pool to make sure she has no she's not
hiding any physical defects so I don't
know what problem this is supposed to
address in Europe yeah this sounds this
sounds dystopian it's more than more
than utopian to me yeah yeah I mean well
waiting for the dystopians of like not
being able to see your wife at all
before you married her I mean in terms
of her nakedness
so I guess it's sort of just like a
slight nod towards the direction of like
okay you want to have a better picture
of your spouse before you know you go
down that path but yeah
um it's it's the religious stuff is
interesting because it seems to be
somewhat separate from the science bits
but actually like for bacon they they
were like very much merged together like
these are very much like religious
scientists they pray when they when they
work and everything and his own kind of
like you know scientific interests and
everything we're very much fueled by his
religious sort of like you know
background and everything so for him
there would have been no distinction
between like this quest for boundless
knowledge and the glorification of God
it was kind of like this exciting
Junction of like you know
knowledge and Faith they kind of work
together is there any evidence that
bacon was secretly like not that
religious or was he for sure really
because when I was reading it I was
thinking to myself you know there's some
like authors and obviously from my
perspective of political Theory you know
I think about like some of the stuff
that uh Leo Strauss would talk about
right hell like when you read the the
Canon you can see that there's maybe
like an esoteric meaning and a lot of
the argument that um that Strauss makes
right is like about the danger of making
certain kinds of claims during when the
at the time when they were writing so I
was kind of thinking about that when I
was reading through this and I was like
because he's leaning so hard into the
Christianity and the Chastity and like
there's a part of me that was like
tempted to almost give like a bit of
astrosian reading and be like well it's
just doing that getting that all out of
the way so then he could make his more
subversive point about like a society
that has like you know strong scientific
commitments right and it's like I'm
gonna say all the nice religious things
about like so that then like the real
meat which as pill says is like a pretty
short section really the message is like
you should have like you know an
advanced University that does like real
inquiry so I don't know but you know
more than me so tell me if he was like I
yeah I I think we can we can probably
safely say like he was genuine in his
like religious commitments and stuff
like that even the name of the
scientific organization on this island
is called Solomon's house which is named
after like the biblical King Solomon so
it's very deeply steeped in this idea of
you know like even at Oxford and
Cambridge you had like King's College
and stuff like that like it was very
much a sort of like religious tradition
that he was working in even in terms of
like the research University and stuff
like that but there there are some
questions about how much he sort of like
overly sort of protests about some
things at least in relation to his
private life because there are theories
for example he might have actually been
queer like Francis Bacon historically
and that's why he goes out of his way to
mention you know and there's definitely
no you know sodomy or anything like that
on this island of like perfect you know
Christian Scientists so yeah there's
definitely ways in which sometimes when
some when one of these authors like
emphasizes something so much it's
usually because they have to almost like
get that out of the way to then get to
the stuff that they really want to talk
about yeah
does seem pretty genuine especially
because like the fact that he's sort of
like showing how you get to the edge of
the world and you still find
Christianity like that sends a powerful
message about like you know there's a
sense of Christian universalism that
like validates our own beliefs and it's
not like you know this is only a
European thing this is like bigger than
us it's really like the true Faith kind
of yeah no that that makes sense I think
the reason why I was like a little bit
tempted too is just because I was I was
like you know trying to imagine myself
in whatever 1646 or whenever this was
published and just like
you know it's kind of the Enlightenment
is in its infancy a little bit there and
you're thinking yourself well how
dangerous would it be to suggest we have
a university that is like committed to
like some kind of rational inquiry or
something like that right and it's like
it's like well the perfect cover would
be like you know tell this story about
finding Christianity in a far away world
it's like in a way it would like it
would it would be like a very convenient
helpful cover to say the really
subversive thing that you're saying I
think I know I mean I think that's a
really modern reading though because of
course I'm sure I I think he I I don't
find the uh the subtlety that Leo
Strauss might in him I think he's very
committed to a universalized
Christianity especially with what's
going on in Europe very committed to it
you know how the uh how natural
philosophy developed out of reading the
book of nature just as like theology was
reading the book of God and we fight we
learn more about God by studying the
stars and his nature that he produced
for us and all this I find that he seems
like he seems like one of those like
died in the war just a just a
biographical note too right this was
written near the end of his life
published after he was dead
um he by by this point he was like in
semi-exile basically uh he had admitted
to accepting bribes while he held a
public office and he was kind of ousted
or marginalized so he's writing this at
a time when he's like way over the hill
and he's getting old and weak and he's
just kind of focusing on like
intellectual stuff at that point writing
this extremely large book that it kind
of was at the tail end of
and and so and I don't know if you
noticed in the story but a couple times
the the functionaries of the new
Atlantis said we don't get paid twice
they wouldn't accept offers from the
crew because they're trying to give them
like pistols or something they kept
trying to give everybody guns and then
and and they kept refusing saying we
don't get paid twice because supposedly
you're getting paid by the state and
then you're not going to use that sort
of power then to charge the people again
who you are providing the services that
the state has contracted you to provide
so that so it's like seemed like a funny
reflection on bacon situation where he
had admitted to accepting bribes and got
ousted so it's like in a perfect Society
no government workers take Kickbacks
right it's always above board in the in
in Atlantis so I looked up I looked this
up because I was like come on 17th
century
like Aristocrat taking bribes this can't
be that bad and it turns out like
everybody did what he did I don't know
I'm not exactly sure maybe you know this
Victor but what like he became a
sacrificial lamb because
of other things that he was doing but
everyone was taking bribes including him
I think he just took the wrong bribes
and was con he was branded corrupt yeah
he fell out of favor with that with the
king's court and you you kind of notice
even in this text how there's a great
emphasis on like none of this is being
done for profit you know none of the
sort of society here is pursuing things
in terms of like they don't want gold
they don't want guns what they're doing
and the the the the sort of idealized
society that The Travelers find is all
driven by knowledge right it's all done
to glorify God and the pursuit of
knowledge so I think that's pretty close
to like Bacon's actual beliefs but it
also probably reflects on like you know
the kind of Scandal that enmeshed him
towards the end of his years too so this
idea is at least like in this thought
experiment that he kind of comes up with
here like it's beyond monetary concerns
he's able to just focus on like what
would the ideal kind of like a research
environment or research University look
like you know without these concerns
about funding or the state's involvement
or anything like that because even
towards the end of this text it's it
seems to be suggested that like the
scientists of the society actually kind
of maybe like run the whole government
to like or they have so much influence
with the state that they're basically
like very important advisors so it does
seem to be the idea that like you know
science and brain Supreme in this sort
of vision of the the society which is
interesting because this is like the
dawn of capitalism England early 17th
century early modern this is like where
it's kicking off and he's uh at least in
this text throwing down his his uh what
would you call it a knowledgeocracy a
rule of the wise yeah and it's very
insulated
that it's very insulated and they
control trade and they control borders
and they control the flow of Travelers
right they don't let people in who are
strangers except under very specific
circumstances and like they're a very
they're also a very controlled Society
right like they have this abundance as
well we shouldn't like it's it's a
Garden of Eden type of situation there
too where they just have this this
extreme abundance and this complete lack
it's like Utopia in this way too
complete lack of concern for for
monetary wealth or what would have
passed for like monetary wealth at the
time gold silver or whatnot they don't
care about that stuff
and it's a completely self-sufficient
yet closed in on itself kind of society
which is you know this is perfectly like
in The Odyssey when when Odysseus washes
up on the the shores of the fiakians on
skoria and meets King al-qinois and his
wife uh out uh forget her name and uh
that it's this sort of perfect Society
way better than the Greek society where
he's from Ithaca uh they have everything
in abundance and they have these but
they have these slightly strange customs
and laws they're different in many ways
too it's like you know I don't know that
Foucault's heterotopia right that kind
of like Strange World in the world this
sort of projection of of something onto
another place that's actually in the
society that the writer is coming from
kind of thing yeah it's really
interesting in that kind of it's like an
anti-cat it would be an anti-capitalist
Society right like they Compares their
border controls to China right he's
saying like it is now but I just want to
quickly note like the context here the
the background for this island is that
once upon a time as The Travelers learn
there was this like ancient age of like
this golden age of global trade right
where like the everybody kind of traded
with everybody thousands of years ago as
The Travelers learned there were ships
back and forth across the Atlantic Ocean
and this is where the myth of Atlantis
also comes into this tale right where he
talks about how actually you know the
place that became known as Atlantis is
actually in the Americas and once that
kind of became flooded and you know you
know the story from Plato then that's
when the society this island of Bensalem
that's when it closed up and since then
they've been much more careful about
kind of you know their contact with the
outside world but there is this
suggestion that like long ago there was
already this age of like global trade
and commerce and that's sort of where
you know like now the world is finally
returning to that state yeah there's
like the second flood they were talking
about that that covered up the Americas
like the almost like the old Atlantis
and and it was like a minor flood it was
it was localized to the Americas and the
way they describe it is I mean this
typical typical age of exploration
nonsensis like uh so therefore the uh
the the natives living on the Americas
are only about a thousand years old
right there are young people uh the ones
who survived were of weak seed and
that's why you know the the ones that
are around aren't very good and they
didn't make art or anything and that
kind of typical colonialist [__] but
the you know the at the new Atlantis
people they survived all this and they
thrived and but they had to turn inwards
no definitely I mean that that part is
actually it's it's very mormon-ish if
you will you mentioned Mormons before
pills because like it kind of like
reinterprets the the the origin of
Native Americans in a very kind of like
European way like it basically subsumes
them into like European cultural
discourses it's like these guys don't
have their own history we're just going
to use them as kind of props in our own
you know foundational stories about the
Bible or Atlantis or whatever yeah so he
talks about or he the traveler in the
story learns about how originally the
so-called island of Atlantis in the
Americas was flooded as a sort of divine
Act of Vengeance or whatever and then
the survivors as as you note Eric were
just the ones who managed to like make
it to the mountains they lost all their
learning all their civilization and then
they became what we now know as like
Native Americans right so they don't
have their culture anymore they don't
really have any knowledge and of course
like this sets things up perfectly then
for kind of okay Europeans to come in
and sort of like colonize the place
because they they the the indigenous
inhabitants basically have no claim
there anymore they've forgotten
everything they're not very cultured or
Advanced so like bacon doesn't actually
believe any of this he's not a Mormon
but but it is interesting how this sort
of alternate history allows him to kind
of um you know speculate on the role of
Europe versus like indigenous
populations and stuff like that so yeah
like there's a lot of yeah I can see the
purpose of a text like this being almost
like Utopia it's like Europeans read
this and then reflect on your own
Society like that's kind of what it
seems like is the purpose here is to get
people thinking about
all of these sorts of you know customs
and laws and this history this tradition
that they Preserve
and this like strange mishmash of kind
of cultures and languages that we find
there which is you know constantly you
know it's it's it's uh compared with
Europe right like you know as as that I
think it was like the Jewish Merchant
was talking about a bunch of different
things saying like no we the Europeans
do it this way we don't do that because
that's not good the Europeans do this
this way but we don't do it that way
like kind of like this is what marriage
is in Europe right it's often just like
a transaction and we we do it here
because we We are following the the
religious you know doctrine of marriage
laid down at the beginning of time or
whatever
yeah it's kind of funny how like in a
lot of the book I just got this sense
that the the People The Travelers were
talking to were just kind of being
boaster braggers they were just like oh
you guys do it this way in Europe like
[__] we do it way better for all these
reasons and like it goes on and on and
it's like it's like we also do this and
we also do this and like we also way
better than you in this way and we're
way better than you in that way and it's
just like wow it's like yeah like all
the liberal arts right he goes through
them like one by one almost he's like
you know mechanics we're better at that
than you and Engineering we build things
that move faster than what yeah we got
people we got this many people working
on this thing and how many do you have
like none we're working on like this
thing we're looking into this thing and
it's like how many do you have none okay
like we're doing all this and it's like
wow holy [__] this guy's an [__] yeah
and in a way like it's sort of like
throwing down the gauntlet for like look
at how you know like perfect a society
could exist but it's also not a
coincidence that this world is set in
the Western Hemisphere right like I
think like in that way yeah it it
comments on Europe but it also I think
definitely serves on some form of as
propaganda to kind of show like okay
think of the riches the knowledge the
wealth that just might be out there you
know maybe not in this you know science
fiction Island that I'm giving you guys
but something like this could be there
because we have to remember also like
this is again like the very early days
of England's Empire they had they
actually had a pretty disastrous
experience at first with like Jamestown
Virginia just a few years before this
where most of the local like most of the
colonizers like starved the first couple
of years so there wasn't really like it
was a very sort of like slow painful
start to this idea of like you know
colonizing the Americas or anything like
that for the English at least so there
was this sense of like we have to
persist with this because look what
awaits us you know in the future perhaps
look at the kind of Ideal World that we
might be able to set up in the Western
Hemisphere based on like the sort of you
know utopian Vision he has here yeah
this is a it's a day one Manifest
Destiny like look we have this entire
empty continent where we could make
Utopia
I mean empty a quote unquote of course
I'm doing this with my fingers listeners
don't worry but yeah they're just
running around naked they don't they
don't
they're not using it anyway maybe we
could talk about because one of the
things like when I was kind of reading
it and then looking up like commenters
on on the significance of this
like you know it's the science and kind
of the the presentation of a lot of
people interpret what he describes as
being kind of like an in anticipation of
the modern University oh yeah
that like a lot of the way he's
describing like how they organize like
Solomon's house their methods of inquiry
a lot of people say well that just
sounds like strikingly what modern
universities do and I guess when I first
read that I was like well didn't Oxford
and Cambridge exist at the time but like
maybe they were just way different than
they are now so like I don't know if you
could offer insight into that no for
sure I mean the focus on like inductive
reasoning especially and like the the
emphasis on like you know scientific
experiments and stuff like that like
this was picking up more and more during
his time like the transition from like
sort of natural philosophy to what we
now think of as like increasingly modern
science and bacon was at the Forefront
of that and you see actually like in
some of the things that he lists even
here just how forward thinking he was
like it's easy to forget this was 400
years ago but some of the experiments
that these like you know these Islanders
are talking about are things that are
basically like you know recording sound
almost like rooms where you can play
images in a way that is almost like a
movie theater all kinds like we have way
better Sounds here
yeah we can record basically like what
we're doing now we can record things we
can change the pitch of people's voices
we can like do all kinds of crazy stuff
that like you know would have been all
inconceivable to actually do like
technically back then but already you
know people were thinking about this
like you know Da Vinci sketching like
helicopters and stuff like that so it's
interesting how you already kind of have
the conceptual sort of like framework
here for like what would be possible
then in like for further centuries and
stuff and like around this point people
are starting to sort of Envision what
you can do especially in terms of like
what you'll notice here like recreating
natural conditions right so every one of
these rooms that the scientists kind of
show The Travelers they have like
different places for like okay this is
like the hot room this is the cold room
this is like the room with water or like
fire like it's all about kind of like um
emulating the natural world and then
manipulating that somehow right so that
seems to be the starting point for them
like thinking about okay do doing these
experiments you start with nature and
then you can kind of like
they perfect that kind of or like
improve on it yeah in your Pursuit yeah
there's a couple paragraphs where they
also talk about
um uh like artificial selection and uh
like manipulate not not in those terms
but like manipulating life forms like
plants and animals and like either
stunting or enhancing their growth or
even I think he says they know how to
transmute plants into trees and trees
back into into like shrub like plants
and and they can they can manipulate the
natural world in all of these ways
that's like you know this is clearly
like Bacon's method promises these kinds
of insights here's a society that has
developed this method to the nth degree
and even on the last pages we get not a
division of labor but a deliver a
division of well labor in The Sciences
right yeah all these with amazing names
by the way the uh the merchants of light
the Mystery Men those sorts of people go
out the
people called the lamps these people go
out and they have this like strict
division like you are looking into the
mechanical Arts you were you are like
trying the experiments you hear about
you are writing them up you are then
like performing further experiments and
like you can see this is sort of like
inductive method coming out here as well
like uh you know it's a direct new
experiments of a higher light and light
is of course the uh well something for
knowledge here the merchants of light
they deal in light they look for light
what you're describing there too is very
much like maybe that's another reason
why your uh people see the modern
University here because it's like
division of labor but also kind of like
specialization right and like maybe
that's the difference with like back
then natural philosophy like there
wasn't really specialization like in the
same sense whereas like that's like a
very modern thing right like you work on
that and you only work on that right
like some of what he was describing
sounded like what they do in like you
know engineering departments right it's
like all they work on is like how to
build this thing right like that's all
they do and it's like that's a very I
guess modern knowledge for its own sake
not in pursuit of that's like what the
lamps job is by the way the lamps job is
to just refine the findings of earlier
scientists what I found hilarious and so
empiricist of him is what do these
people do for fun well they have
something called the house of Deceit so
you're not allowed the the thing that an
empiricist is most afraid of is his
senses being deceived so if you want
your senses to be deceived and to get
pleasure out of it you have to go only
you're only allowed to do it in one
place the house of Deceit that's where
all like the card sharks and all the uh
you know the the ball in the cup all of
The Magicians they're all in the Hall of
the deceit and of Deceit they can't
trick anyone they can't do any damage we
just go in there for fun once in a while
there's someone in there with like a cup
of water dipping a stick into it like
look how it bends
oh my God
a
mirror something it would have been like
too much for him to process it's like
real but it's not there it's yeah but
yeah it the house of Deceit especially
is almost like again it's like like an
early kind of like idea of like the
cinema almost where like we're gonna put
up images they're not really real they
also have like I think that the
mathematical house in one case which is
like basically like a computer room
where like equations will be done that
humans can't you know possibly you know
like keep up with and stuff so
yeah very very Advanced very specialized
as you know Victor and um really
interesting in terms of how like again
all of this is under the auspices of
like you know a religious sort of you
know framework we're gonna praise God as
we do this and everything but you can
see here as well like he briefly
mentions oh yeah and there's also a
place for like weapons of war we also
study that and it's like a passing
mention but like all of this of course
is ultimately like you know the the
questions of it how much of this sort of
like technology and stuff is going to
also be in the service of like you know
Colonial expansion like broader like you
know government projects and stuff
because
um there's a very famous quote which is
often attributed to bacon which is like
knowledge itself is power or sientia
S so like this idea of like okay
knowledge for its own sake is all well
and good but ultimately like there's
obvious material benefits from this kind
of like study there's gonna be like you
know the the nation which can harness
this kind of like advanced technology is
basically going to be able to conquer
the world right so there seems to be
that suggestion as well underlying some
of this but here's here's the stated
purpose of Atlantis their sort of
overarching shared goal or what they
call the end of our foundation the goal
of our foundation which it is the
knowledge of causes and secret motions
of things and the enlarging of the
bounds of human Empire to the affecting
of all things possible so almost like
human Empire and affecting all things
possible I meant like coming into I
don't know
realizing its potential doing everything
that's possible that stuff and also the
causes and secret motions of things so
like insights into uh what makes nature
tick basically the the Natural Science
the the Holy Grail of Natural Science in
the service of the expansion of human
fire and presumably good living
and you're right yeah so he directly
mentions human Empire there and I mean
like this is the sort of like the the
local scientist who's showing them
around so this can mean you know be
taken more abstractly as like the bounds
of human knowledge but you know it's not
a coincidence like the Empire part of it
is clearly sort of of interest to like
Bacon's readers and his audience at the
time and so like and you get that of
course like of course later on you know
the British would dominate the seas
because of their like Naval superiority
technology was Central to that and then
of course even with the Americans and
everything how much they invested in
like research and development after
World War II like science and even like
the modern research University and like
places like MIT and stuff and their
relation with like centers of power in
the government are always intertwined to
an extent which is like you know even
here it's like almost tangible how much
like this is all waiting to be used in
service of like you know some sort of a
broader project
though he doesn't bring that up I did
want to bring up um this might derail a
little bit but like about a hundred
years later we get Jonathan Swift the uh
novel or we call them a novelist he's a
writer
exactly that is a satirist and he
satirizes basically this story where
uh Gulliver goes to an island called
laputa which means the [__] of course
he goes to the island the [__] and it's
a bunch of slaves
it's like Elysium that film that I never
watched but there's a bunch of slaves
they are grinding away they have to cut
food into into like geometrical shapes
and then there's a floating island above
all the slaves that are on the ground
and this is where the scientists rulers
live and the scientists rulers they they
can only they they can't build anything
at right angles so all their houses are
gone to [__] they have to be wake woken
up from their daydreaming because they
just Daydream all day but the slave one
of the slave's job is just to wake them
up so about a hundred years after this
we get this first this Rosy picture like
we have a whole continent just waiting
for us to bring our knowledge to it and
and we can have these independent
institutions that are not part of
rulership how do we get from there to
100 years later the horror Island where
these very privileged old men fall
asleep because their their potatoes
aren't cut into perfect pyramid shapes
well there's a few Civil Wars between uh
bacon and Swift that kind of sours the
mood on some of this stuff so
essentially yeah but by the time Swift
is writing in the 18th century there's a
much greater focus on satire skepticism
of some of these utopian projects and
there's a lot more kind of like
playfulness with this idea of like you
know the idealized society or the Utopia
narrative by by this point this is by by
that point the genre has kind of played
itself out to where people are kind of
like you know taking the piss a little
bit of like the sort of baconian
narrative so that's where Swift is
coming from with this stuff and he goes
to like even greater lengths to kind of
criticize other aspects of like English
society in indirectly in that novel in
Gulliver's Travels through like you know
the different lands where like there's
there's Giants or there's dwarves
everything is kind of like magnified in
different ways in ways that again like
it's all ultimately like a caricature or
cartoon of like modern Europe at the
time but bacon is like basically doing
this straight like he's not like remote
there's no humor in any of this like he
genuinely like wants this kind of like
world to one day be like a reality so
for him again like the actual like
economics of it are quite fuzzy in terms
of how this is even possible but I think
that yeah like it's it's also worth
noting like we haven't really touched on
how like um the reason why the
inhabitants of this island of Ben solemn
are able to even have this technology
and everything and to be so wise is
because like not only do they have the
sort of Christian Revelation thousands
of years ago but they had contact with
like the Hebrews the Greeks the
Egyptians like again it goes back to
this ancient sort of world of like
Commerce and like trade before the
floods before Atlantis fell and that's
where it all kind of like comes from so
again there's that sense as well like
the context the ancient history there of
like how this is even possible it's
because they were around for like the
initial sort of like you know cultural
foundations of all this stuff yeah
that's that's another one of the like
major pillars I think of this whole
concept is that you have science and and
and and and kind of abundance
at the at the heart of all of this but
you also have this strong sense of
tradition which seems to present a
couple different like dimensions of
anxiety one of them is is the religious
Dimension where they are extraordinary
religious and it there's some anxiety
over you know like Jewish people being
there but they're like our Jews aren't
like other Jews so that's cool the other
Jews hate Jesus these ones don't so
great and and but then but then the
patriarchy of it all too like right the
the way that he envisions tradition is
he can only Envision this patriarchal
society which you know is is again we
all know it's kind it's almost like it's
almost like a cliche now you don't know
who your father is right like without
DNA testing so there's all this anxiety
over patriarchy and the and the kind of
way they're so benevolent towards it
although it's like you know these guys
who have 30 kids uh they they get like
you know elevated and worshiped so they
set up this almost like meritocratic
achievement of of being a being a
patriarch and then that he he even says
you know and and like if the kid is born
to a different mother
uh that like it's okay we don't do
anything about that we don't exclude
them socially we just don't allow them
to inherit and more than a certain like
small chunk of their thoughts so it kind
of keeps everything like you know
patriarchal and down the lineages right
it keeps everything kind of neat and
tidy there's no in this Society there's
no there's no anxiety in this Society
over you know your birth
paid out like the the collapse of the
patriarchy and that sort of thing right
because it's very strongly you know it's
it's incentivized it's it's elevated to
a kind of almost like to a way of
getting into Politics as well it's like
all connected so there's this huge like
yeah tradition has these different faces
and you can imagine that these reflect
like huge anxieties at the time in
Europe over these various things you
know non-christians you know yeah how do
you know who your progeny is that sort
of stuff and you're touching on
something really cool here which is like
this sort of what what's most romantic
and idealized about Bacon's World here
is that like this idea that you could
have this sense of scientific
achievement and still have it within
like a Christian framework right because
that's where we actually start to have
trouble with it as modern readers
because like we we're so used to
thinking of like religion and Science in
like different camps and that's where
the rupture comes like later in the 17th
century after Bacon's time with all the
Civil War and everything where like
basically like in the enlightenment of
course which was no longer really rooted
in like a Christian framework is like
Bacon's Vision never really happened
because in order for like the sort of
technical advancements to keep
continuing and everything like the
Christian worldview inevitably was
challenged right you couldn't still have
this idea of like you know biblical
knowledge and still have like actual
empiricism actual like objective
knowledge of the world because
eventually of course contradiction
started to emerge right so that's where
that's where the tension comes and I
think that you note as well Eric between
like there's this deep sense of
traditionalism here but at the same time
bacon also wants like genuine boundless
scientific advancement and the two can
actually go together as would be like
borne out by history but yeah they can
still dreams that you that this is
possible and we know of course it wasn't
like the enlightenment had to sort of
like put aside Christianity to kind of
really continue with this sort of stuff
and then just just even get getting
getting real sophomore here now is that
this motif of light too right I mean
while you're thinking I was just I was
just thinking yeah they're so Advanced
and yet they never really looked into
that weird pillar of light phenomenon
that they that they claim founded their
religious uh their religious
institutions but okay let's ignore that
but the pillar of light right the
merchants of light go around and get
knowledge and the pillar of light is
what gave them the Revelation or
whatever knowledge of God and then you
have them also near the end making
bragging about how they can make
flashlights that project light much
further than yours do and we could make
things that are brighter than what you
can make and we can even make like
non-light bodies hold lights kind of
like they have this is this weird
description of like what they can do
with their kind of light science and we
can even uh isolate the um the the
Rainbow Band of the prison and we can
isolate them into their different light
components and like all this all all the
stuff he's bragging about to the visitor
all the the um I believe this is the
last encounter so this this motif of
light keeps coming up and up again and
it's connected to yeah their religion
their knowledge finding kind of mission
and and even some of the inventions that
they kind of go on and on about as well
so it's this
I don't know and then that brings my
mind forward to someone like Matthew
Arnold who's talking about the sweetness
and light of of European culture as
light being kind of a simultaneously
both religious Revelation and scientific
knowledge light lighting the world and
the soul and all that stuff and bringing
light and yeah it's it's a weird Motif
but it it works here anyway
in this short span of uh of a story yeah
well pills you're the resident expert on
uh metaphors of visual light and
knowledge and everything so doesn't that
also go back to Plato or oh at least but
yeah
yeah it's continued and of course God
adds like God is light like the people
who do the science they're called like I
said the lamps
um and this is like the
I don't you know the city the city on
the hill the light outside of The Bushel
this is like meant to be the the model
that European Society follows that's
coming out of a philosopher's brain
yeah but interestingly there's no
there's no prisons here there's no slave
camps there's no there's no slaves
are there wait let me see not that it's
mentioned yeah like who's who's growing
the food in this Society
just the machines
seemingly it's it's just so easily
available all it needs to be is pick to
distributed
but I there is technology for like
farming and stuff too so the idea is
yeah like science has solved everything
it seems to be the the working
assumption here well I can yeah what I
got most out of this we're kind of in a
wind down stage I think but what I got
most out of this is like if this is the
attitude not just a unique singular guy
but if this is the attitude that's
inspiring the colonial project the
scientific project just
and you can't blame him for that for
being like uh for being uh ethnocentric
obviously you'd expect that but it kind
of makes sense looking at the century
that followed this if this is the if
this is the best we could ever hope for
we have a perfect picture of it like in
Utopia or in this text we have a perfect
picture of a scientific religious
society that can just move into P places
where there's
there's like primitive Primitives
they're they're they're running around
naked because they're only a thousand
years old we should bring them this
light we shouldn't keep this light to
ourselves it wouldn't be Christian
so there is like absolutely no sense of
that other and I think this is like this
is actually because you mentioned Star
Trek at the beginning there's always an
episode like this right where they come
to some perfect society and the society
is running completely functionally and
someone guides them around but then
there's always something like really
evil that they're doing too that's kept
out of that's kept out of vision and I
think that's uh true of this story too
is you know like they need to sacrifice
a child once a year or something that's
their sick big secret yeah there's
another city where everyone's growing
food and enslaved for the or they just
have to be really boring in chassed yeah
yeah
yeah so uh
what was your favorite part of the city
would be to uh hang out in yeah the
movie theater I think that the house of
Deceit the house at the seat does sound
fun math house sounds real boring
yeah I don't know that the house of
smells might be fun though the perfume
house you just go in there and uh you
just get to like smell things it says we
we imitate smells making all smells to
breathe out of other mixtures like okay
yeah that would be fun like that go into
like the the bay and go to the perfume
section yeah all right this is like a
this is like a a mall he's describing
these are all the stores in our in our
Mall come come visit I like I I would
actually want to talk more to the the
wise Jew as he says it it's so like it's
it's a really interesting reference
there because like he he's sort of like
you know nodding again to how like you
know it's not just this idealized view
of like this the the Western Hemisphere
being like ripe for European settlement
but like we're also going to like you
know kind of like assimilate Europe's
minorities into this like Ideal World
where like you know even like you know
this this Jewish Merchant who he the The
Traveler comes across is just like he he
loves Jesus as we said he's somebody was
like you know so he's he's totally part
of the system there's no difference
there either so like it's everything is
like sanitized there's no rough edges
there's no like you know it's all very
homogeneous in that way and which it's
just like it's so clearly like idealized
but it's very revealing that like even
the minor even like the European
minorities here and like the Jewish
murder even the even the Jews realize
how good we are totally non-threatening
I want to read that this is this is so
funny I was fallen into strange
acquaintance with a merchant of that
City whose name was joabin
very Jewish sounding name he was a Jew
and circumcised for they have some few
sterps of jute I don't know what a sterp
is but they have some few sterps of Jews
remaining yet among them who leave to
their own religion which they made the
better do because they are a far
differing disposition from the Jews of
other parts for whereas they hate the
name of Christ and have a secret inbred
Rancor against the people of whom they
live this is other Jews
they hate the people they live around
these give unto their savior many high
attributes and love the nation of
Bensalem extremely surely this man of
whom I speak would ever acknowledge that
Christ was born of a virgin and that he
was more than a man unlike the rancorous
inbred Jews of Europe
this guy thinks that Jesus was actually
born from a virgin
and it's worth noting too like England
basically kicked out their Jewish
population like in the 1200s so they had
no Jews it was that bad like there was
no reference point even so it really
like England was very homogeneous at
this time it was all like different
Christian denominations of course kind
of squabbling but that was the main sort
of difference that the idea of like
anything beyond that was almost
inconceivable so you see just how much
of a struggle it is even for bacon to
like think of like what would it really
mean to have like
a different kind of like perspective a
different culture here and it's it's all
there's very little of that it's all one
model of things
so you read this primarily as like
utopian fiction then like right oh we
talked about kind of speculative science
fiction and travel narratives but I I
think I've read this primarily as a
utopian novel or Novella it's like
describing a place that's very ideal and
awesome and everybody's needs are taken
care of
that's how I kind of think of it yeah I
was just gonna say I read it kind of as
like Bacon's great unfulfilled DND
campaign because he's clearly World
building here to an extent that like
he's eager to share with people but
yeah no it's it's clearly very fantasy
it's it's clearly very much kind of
aspirational in a way which like is
doomed to remain abstract because again
there's that like irreconcilable tension
between the Christianity of it and the
actual objective empiricism that he
wants to pursue but I think it also kind
of like you can't separate it again from
the colonial project that like England
was increasingly undertaking at this
time like there's clearly a lot of like
propaganda here which is meant to like
you know excite people about the new
world and especially like the dirty
secret of the society like we were
talking about you know what's what's
what are they hiding what's what's the
flaw in the system and of course we know
what the actual dirty secret was like
historically he's like it's the Atlantic
slave trade that's what's gonna happen
over the next decades which actually
makes the sort of colonial project
possible is the sort of enslavement of
one continent to kind of build another
one so that's what's sort of missing
from the picture here is like what was
actually possible in making the Americas
kind of like a reality and that's where
you know they didn't live to see that
but it's it's coming yeah this is what
you get when you have a philosopher
write a work of fiction which they
should always avoid doing
yeah I get you can you know you get he's
a man of science too right you get those
flashbacks especially in the part where
he describes animal experimentation back
to like the Cartesian kinds of
demonstrations that Descartes would do
just like cut open an animal here it's
like animal testing right we don't we
don't uh give anybody the cures until
we've tested them out on animals first
and we also just do tests on animals for
fun to increase our own knowledge that's
kind of them the thing here which
wouldn't age so well in this whole
picture but among other things
I think if you read this more like in
the context or in the tradition of
something like Plato's Republic or again
Thomas Moore's Utopia that's where you
kind of understand like okay like this
isn't really like yes he's just dressing
it up a little bit with like a travel
account kind of but ultimately he's just
saying like this is the kind of society
I would love to see you know like this
is my dream kind of like world it's less
so than an actual story you know with
characters or anything like that you
know the the main thing I missed that I
was looking for in this was almost like
a
um like a landscape kind of a geographic
geometrical kind of description right
because like
Thomas Moore kind of employs that almost
like a very careful like sort of um
almost land survey geometrical
description like there's there's a
spatial element missing here and like
like when you look at like sort of I
don't know old Utopia paintings from the
Renaissance right they're using like
their one point perspective and
mathematical effective to
to project these sort of symmetrical
perfect places and even in the
literature they describe them that way
there wasn't actually a lot of that
going on here like even if you think of
you know Dante's Inferno right like very
geographical right and rings and rings
and rings and like everything has this
spatial logic but that was missing here
I don't know it's just something I
expected but didn't get maybe he would
have gotten there
or maybe this was all or maybe yeah like
for for the scope of this kind of
thought experiment he's he's not even
interested so much in the geography of
it it's just more like the concepts of
like how would this Society look like
you know socially rather than
geographically because you're right
there's a lot of the World building is
still has some gaps that need to be
filled in
yeah like how everything would be
divided in space is not there that seems
to be a big part of utopian thinking
though is actually how to spatially
organize things not just you know this
sort of
this sort of logical organization where
you have all the needs covered and then
this nice flow of scientific division of
labor
yeah but I don't know I thought that was
an interesting thing not to see but
life of the mind he's not interested in
like walking upon the Earth
yeah you can tell he's a scientist first
philosopher
yeah it brought corrupt politician yeah
yeah yeah yeah you get you get his
science you get his science disposition
here very clearly near the end
but I mean he was a man of politics and
all kinds of other things so you know
you get their foreign policy then you
get there in domestic policy then you
get there sort of
science right at the end
which is very
I mean it's a short read it's worth it's
worth plowing through yeah
up on Gutenberg for free and I'll put in
the description but we've talked it
um thank you very much Victor for
bringing that to us that was fun
I'm I'm
through the course of the discussion I
think it struck me like what you said
this is this this utopian Vision has an
engine but the engine is not part of the
light the engine is outside of the light
in the uh
in the Dark Continent
yes so that we can have our Raytheon
buildings yeah even the hopes that he
has for this like
knowledge for the sake of knowledge and
pursue completely separate from the
market or completely separate from
Warfare
didn't really turn out but you can kind
of see the engine of this kind of
colonial thought where it comes from
yeah and even though again it is very
much dressed up in this sort of utopian
you know science fiction kind of uh
genre it is very much a Manifesto for
like this is what the new world could
look like let's get busy so that's kind
of very interesting here yeah or even
like a more personal note of like that
this is what society would look like if
they implemented my scientific method
and then perfectly married it to a kind
of patriarchal religious political
institution that that could exist in in
perfect harmony with this this science
and knowledge side of things then this
is what you would get so Europe you're
falling behind here seems like he's
saying too which maybe this is some of
his own religious and personal beliefs
too it is worth just quick quickly
noting as a final thought that some of
the ideas here did influence the
formation of the Royal Society later in
the 1660s so which was it's still
England's Academy of Sciences so later
on parts of this do actually get picked
up in like um England itself yeah like
they didn't even if even if he was being
ironic like like Leo Strauss might have
suggested they didn't take it to be
ironic they took it quite seriously it
seems in hindsight I just just on a
lighter note I want to add that some of
the scientific explanations are so funny
when they're saying like look what we
can do is first of all I had a thought
experiment what if I was that guy and I
was explaining to someone from another
planet what we could do I'd be like look
I just pick up this thing and I've hit
it a few times then there's a pizza at
the door like oh beat that Atlantis [__]
you but other and then what other
descriptions was uh look what we can do
we have an object that can make distant
things appear closer and I'm like oh
great that's a telescope and then he's
like and we have something that can make
close things appear far away and I was
like he just he's looking at the wrong
end of the telescope there that's not
that's not cool that's stupid I thought
he was going to say make small things
look really big like oh there's a
microscope no you're just looking in the
telescope the wrong way you idiot he
does mention I think like they have like
kind of microscopes for like looking at
blood and everything and like catching
diseases so like this is yeah again very
forward thinking for that time so
because like telescopes had just been
used like in the previous decades
basically by like Galileo and stuff for
the first time to study astronomy so
Bacon's already thinking of like let's
like it reverse that and look at like
you know microscopes and like germs and
stuff so yeah no I he does mention the
microscopes but he I think there is a
separate part about like the telescope
making yeah it's close things look far
away and I was like respective houses
yeah yeah I was like that's completely
useless but that's a hilarious thing to
brag about
it's like I have this little thing that
can when I look through it it makes a
kaleidoscope appear and you can't really
see anything but it just looks cool so
here you go impressive eh yeah it's got
no use but I I just thought that was
hilarious eating tried to impress him
with a backwards telescope all right
nice
all right well why don't we leave it
there for today uh Victor do you want
people to follow you or anything
sure yeah I'm I'm on Twitter and uh
other than that yeah just uh check this
book out I mean it's a very quick read
it's only 30 40 pages and it's you might
be surprised by just how much again it
has elements of like uh science fiction
like modern genres that we can kind of
tell like originated actually in this
really interesting kind of like early
modern Renaissance kind of uh Global
Imperial environment so some really cool
stuff there what are you on Twitter
again Horatio Horatio Victor
which is my middle name oh is it
Shakespeare literary reference
I I would never stoop solo it actually
is my middle name so
all right thank you very much and uh
we'll see you again you know if you have
access to comment sections
give give us questions for Vic because
we're gonna we're gonna at least have
you back to talk about your dissertation
but anything all things early modern
he's a wealth of knowledge history all
that stuff great Disney movies Disney
movies yeah let's do the original man
yeah all right yeah you gotta have a
couple of areas of specialty
take care audience
adios
[Music]
foreign